Speaker 1: Let's do a quick look through a
recent press conference that Republican Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Green gave.
As we talked about earlier in the week, she
now has apologized and said, you know, when
I compared stuff to the Holocaust, that was
wrong.
There's nothing like the Holocaust.
She learned at age 47 that the Holocaust is
really bad.
And some people thought, hey, you know what,
she seems sincere.
Maybe things are going in the right direction
with Marjorie Taylor Greene.
Very much.
Not at all.
Here she is yesterday being asked, have you
been vaccinated?
And check out what she says.
Speaker 4: And I stand with the Americans
that want their privacy and whoever gives
us gives us rights to privacy with our medical
information.
And so I appreciate you asking, but that is
my right to keep my medical information private.
Speaker 1: And so understand that Pippa has
nothing to do with journalists asking her
questions.
This is being used frequently by the right.
And sometimes these talking points just they
get they get a head of steam.
It's like a runaway train.
Hipper, hipper.
Sean Hannity said the same things on his show
a few weeks ago.
He said, you know, I was going to talk about
my vaccination decision, but all these people
now are asking me, have you been vaccinated?
And hip up medical privacy.
Hippo relates to medical providers and your
information and the safe keeping of it.
Doctors can't say whether you are or aren't
a patient unless you've authorized them to
do it.
Your medical records have to be kept safe
and private, etc..
A journalist saying, have you been vaccinated
to a politician, particularly one who's a
public figure has nothing to do with hip hop.
And this was not the only wacky thing that
happened here.
The Republican attacks on Dr. Fauci continued.
Here is Marjorie Taylor Greene talking about
that.
Speaker 4: The fire foushee actually brain.
Dr. Fauci, by the way,
Speaker 1: the Fire Foushee Act, this this
is a delusional person,
Speaker 4: salary down to zero and also will
require the Senate to confirm someone to fill
his position.
Right.
You see, Dr. Fauci was not elected by the
American people.
Speaker 1: Yes.
As he has not, which is not uncommon for lots
of people in positions of medical significance
Speaker 4: chosen to guide our economy.
Speaker 1: He was not.
And he literally says when asked, I am not
an economic person.
We actually have it's funny.
She says he was not chosen to guide our economy.
There have been times where Dr. Fauci has
been asked questions during hearings about
how would you evaluate this guideline with
its economic impact.
And Dr. Fauci straight up says, I'm not an
economics guy.
I just make medical recommendations.
That's for economists or politicians or for
whoever else to actually talk about and decide.
Speaker 4: Not chosen to rule over parents
and their children's education,
Speaker 1: and then that's more of this stuff
about Foushee is the Democrats and Foushee
and people who have medical opinions are in
some way dictatorial overlords over the general
public, which is funny because 30 or 40 percent
of the country didn't do a damn thing of all
the different things that were recommended
by medical professionals.
So very weak Overlordship is what it sounds
like.
And then lastly, Marjorie Taylor Green also
asked about her continued use of the term
China virus, and she said it's not it has
nothing to do with race.
Speaker 2: You call it the China virus.
You suggest that it's a bio weapon.
There's no evidence of any of that.
And we're also in the middle of a spate of
attacks against Asian-Americans.
Are you just feeding that produce?
Speaker 4: Absolutely not.
Absolutely not.
You're not going to turn this into something
else.
This is a virus that killed all kinds of people.
It had nothing.
It has nothing to do with anyone's race or
ethnicity, has nothing to do with any of that.
Speaker 1: Well, but OK.
But nationality at minimum, right?
I mean, still calling it the China virus.
Not at all.
So there she's just dismissing that completely
out of hand.
So this this is a really gross woman, guys,
as if you couldn't tell of just completely
disgusting person and whether she was really
serious in her apology about the Holocaust
stuff, I don't know, but certainly not someone
who seems to be on the path to making any
more sense recently.
That's
for sure.